Oh
well there are very thoughtful people
they're concerned about the human factor
in warfare and in defense after all
their job is to defend Americans from
people bad people who want to come and
blow up airplanes and do all that sort
of stuff and it's a real fear it's a
real concern as we sadly no but for
example if you look at the General
Petraeus doctrine in Afghanistan and in
Iraq earlier the first thing was to find
out about the people who are they
they're not just furniture and so one of
the things that it's possible to do in
an organization like the Department of
Defense is provide some insight into how
human beings are likely to behave for
example if a lot of foreigners come with
guns they're not going to like it
they're simply not going to like it and
so we see recently President Karzai of
Afghanistan saying that you know he's
going to join the Taliban well he's
tired of these Americans particularly
after President Obama came to visit him
to give him a rebuke about his
corruption what Obama thought was
corruption and what Karzai thinks is
just being a decent relative to his
brother and all the other people and
he's got to be responsible for so those
are some of the issues that are
necessary to understand in the world of
in a dangerous world and I don't see any
problem in doing that what causes
somebody to get on an airplane with bomb
and in his underwear he's got a belief
and he didn't get that belief from
eating a kit kat bar he got it from some
discernible series of events in his life
that convinced him that this is what he
should do put him in contact with bomb
makers and various associates who
provided in the airplane ticket and the
like and he ended up as it happened
getting caught but
there was a human trail there then that
could have been tracked and in future
there will be another such event and if
we can catch it well good if we can some
lots of people will die